love it or hate it the orp is just one
of the coolest guns in gaming it's high
risk it's high reward and it really
takes a true artist to bring out its
full potential that's why this week we
wanted to pay our respects to those
skilled enough to pull off some of the
most insane or plays in cs go now you
know we've made several alt videos in
the past and as much as we love to play
the classics this time around we're
going to try our best to give some love
to the other brilliant plays
and also before we start i want to let
you guys know about a brand new series
on our channel we just released our
second episode of every second counts
presented by cisco which breaks down
stewie's incredible clutch at the boston
major you can find a link to the episode
in the description below alright then
it's time let's get into the top 10 all
plays in cs go history
kicking off our list is devices ace
against team vitality at esl one cologne
i can't believe he's just done that that
is so
so disgusting from device he's telling
zai wu i was here all year as one of the
best stoppers in the world and i can
deliver just as good when you win as
many tournaments and majors as device
has you're bound to pick up some truly
nasty highlights along the way device
took it upon himself to grab some big
green and wipe out vitality with one of
the filthiest aces we've ever seen but
they do have a three-man stack on this
side devices had a really rough game
flashed he's gonna get that shot and it
has to feel a little bit good out middle
of the air to take down alex another
pushing oh
he takes every single one
from nothing to the awps
this is just greedy the man had three
teammates with him on site and they
didn't even get to hit their opponents
kenny takes the number nine spot now
with this old-school clutch against nip
kenny s with no armor running straight
onto the side can he get to safety he
manages to get out of this first
position picks up the frag onto aloo
goes for the quick second shot forest is
causing oh my goodness so much damage
done here by kenny yes another frag
found and again kenny s four kills in a
row very few cs go players can come
close to matching the level of
mechanical skill kenny had with the orb
in his prime finds the pick i think
that's in towards palace if i'm not
mistaken nicely done and dennis before
positioning doesn't pay off that kenny
is ready for that one yeah can he ask oh
my
at star series seven titan was on match
point but nip were close behind trying
to push things to overtime with almost
no hope of winning kenny s found himself
alone in a corner facing off against
four members of nip but that's child
play for kenny s kenny s with no armor
running straight on to the side can he
get to safety he manages to get out of
the exposed position picks up the frag
onto aloo goes for the quick second shot
forest is causing oh my goodness so much
damage done here by kenny yes another
frag found and again kenny s four kills
in a row and there it is 16 14 and that
is fantastic there from kenny s
at number eight we have the one and only
simple and his insane 4k against team
liquid at iem katowice you better start
calling him sasha the smasher this is
unbelievable the awp
look simple should be allowed to do
whatever he wants whenever he wants on
the server the man is the goat for a
reason he catches off the plan 14
seconds they've got to get out simple
gets only one in return jumps up and
somehow finds sergey but he hasn't found
the bomb he will now and he goes away
from default because he doesn't want to
get naked he also knows there's a flank
and he also knows he needs position he
actually gets the first one he's got a
chance he knows aloo's up close and he's
around oh that's what we like from
simple even a 1v4 doesn't phase this guy
team liquid came at him with rifles at
the ready and simple still mowed them
all down
trying to catch one and he does flame
he's gone down and now just perfecto and
simple he needs a multi-kill first found
twist aggressing they have to double
peak he's getting his shots he's hitting
another one simple oh simple that's
unbelievable what in his name number one
in the game he's done it again you
better start calling him sasha the
smasher this is unbelievable the awp we
know he's got it in him i didn't think
that round would be possible though like
we said let the man do whatever he wants
when he's on he's on i mean he landed an
actual 360 no scope that same game on
the other side of the smoke they're
going to try and split towards b
one shot connecting no
you can't do that ridiculous
this wouldn't be a proper orb list
without including the godfather himself
which is why our seventh spot goes to
fallen and his crazy clutch against faze
that is all fallen that is incredible
that he goes beyond the threat and takes
the defuser next to world-class
footballers and soybeans fallen might be
brazil's greatest export he's a two-time
major winning igl that still pulls off
insane or plays after all these years
seemingly a three on two a five on two
right every single time still winnable
falling needs the ace clutch he's got
two
oh come on fallen yeah the blood's
flowing now
oh
now as nutty as that ace was we need to
travel back to 2017 and the sk era for
the real entry on this list think back
to iem sydney where faze was slowly
crawling back on map 1. it was a 2v4 and
faze was defusing the bomb so fallen
pulled off an insanely ballsy play to
save the round and win the map as they
both get close enough rain considering
upper has aloo go look low hits the
defuser
that is incredible that might be the
game in itself an absolutely brilliant
play from fallen as he nails both shots
it's on to nico he's heard phelps drop
back down but he's got to try and bait
out the time and phelps won't allow nico
to work with much he's down to 10 and he
goes to the off for desperation but
phelps has had enough and sk win it that
has all fallen that is incredible to not
just hit the defuser but to follow up
with a quick scope on aloe now that's
the fallen we know and love
after that map win sk would go on to
beat our phase and win iam sydney
kickstarting sk's domination that year
have returned to four and they dominated
2016.
they won summit but they've yet to win a
premiere in 2017
so nice we had to feature him twice here
at our sixth spot is the time he pulled
off an unbelievable ace on team liquid
that is unheard of device doing them
dirty molly's and incendiaries have been
a badass part of some of cs go's most
memorable plays at iem global challenge
2020 device added to that list of
incredible plays when he managed to
complete an ace with a collateral while
on fire fights are about to come over
device is even here to help out and now
while it is good for one they give it
the respect to get back to the car that
might be their undoing the short play
now from twists oh device reads it in
with the flick burning alive and the
collateral in the flames the ace for
device and what a way to put up 14. that
is unheard of device doing them dirty
cracking the top five is nitro and his
4k against navi at iem cologne 2019.
that might be the killing blow
as nitro
he comes online i told you that awp is
something else when it comes online
nitro will likely go down as one of the
greatest north american igls in cs go
history he captained team liquid during
their most dominant era and the
aftermath of his departure from cs go
was felt for some time and despite
primarily being a rifler he proved time
and time again that he wasn't too shabby
with the orp but they remain a man down
and 31 seconds nitro changes that with
the first and the second looking
he gets a third looking for the fourth
doesn't even matter at this point
stewie's on it nitro has gotten that
point what a round of the awp
very few people are able to beat simple
with the orb but to add three kills on
top of that and lead your team to win
the intel grand slam that's something
only nitro could do
claiming the force but on our list is
chris j and his ace on mirage the wolf
of wall street gets an ace and it's
championship point mo sports chris j is
historically one of the more
underappreciated authors in cs go i mean
just take a look at his career it's a
wonder why some people don't put more
respect on his name
pretty big part of the burden that goes
with him flashbang in canon
oh my god he flicked headshots rpk that
is outrageous but at esl one new york
2018 chris j really threw the gauntlet
down as he made a mess of team liquid to
secure match point in the grand finals
wants to try and hold off the rotations
oscar's gone chris isn't up still in the
picture oh still very much in the realm
oh chris he's found three it's down to
it
chris can he close this with an ace oh
my god
damn i just realized liquid is on the
receiving end of a lot of these plays
probably nothing to read into there
you just knew this one had to be on the
list at number three it's cadian and his
clutch to win esl pro league season 13.
[Applause]
yes we know that the cadian clutch is
quickly becoming the new olaf boost but
please allow us the indulgence we don't
need to set this one up for you the man
had a p250 and you know the rest oh yeah
ah yeah
oh my god he's knifed him and he's
gotten away with the or punch time to
get nervous
there's no way there's no way katie you
can't win pro league like this you can't
win pro league like this
no way
exiles left 40 seconds in the bombs on a
take your time son you're about to make
the play of your career
he just has to hit this shot and he's
done it for heroic
the leader
calling well above his years clearing
corners
and i just can't believe it 40 of their
team only together since february
taking the runner-up spot on our list of
greatest or plays is wakzik and his
heroic ace against eg
unbelievable scenes alex
it was a questionable pick towards the
underpass position but my god does he
ever deliver walksik is typically known
as a calm and collected individual but
sometimes an orphan needs to have that
fire in their eyes you know that kind of
fire that helps them swing a game with
just a few shots roxic showed that fire
off at esl pro league season 10 when he
threw caution to the wind and slapped
down one of the most incredible aces we
have ever seen is he really going to
take this fight again it's creek versus
zorp and precise as always
an eleventh for walks it get a crucial
opener for mousesports
it was six in a row
[Music]
number one spot we need to bend the
rules just a little bit because our
greatest ought play goes to nifty and
his infamous 50 bomb against mouse
sk on the side of the australians why
wouldn't you be at this stage i think
everyone is are we right
nifty is an incredible author he's
likely one of the world's flashiest and
you can't really argue when pulling off
[ __ ] like this
can see the kill pop up in the feed but
he will have another crack
at a shot and this time he does deliver
oh nifty
that is disgusting and look where the
bombs drop now as well but nifty truly
showed the world the orb is just an
extension of his body at iam sydney 2018
where he pulled off the most incredible
individual performance in cs go history
well they do need to stop the rot
because renegades are certainly coming
back into this match and nifty now but
they need more nifty gets a connection
onto chris j and steps up against oscar
as well oh nifty he's bringing out the
goods in this another one he's a madman
and a sharp shooter nifty dropped 50
kills in one game against renegades it
was somehow both clinical and
disrespectful it's like nifty was just
playing a completely different game both
teams have been throwing absolutely
everything at each other and look at
this what on earth nifty wow movement
but what makes this game even more
special is that nifty was throwing down
for renegades on their home soil i'm not
sure what it takes to get citizenship in
australia but nifty's whole family
should definitely have it by now still
player advantage for the renegades but
they must wait for that rotation to come
across and nifty the hero right now for
the renegades keeping them in this map
we'll spot out the final player as well
and two massive rounds
all right then those were our top 10 orc
plays in cs go history now like i said
at the start of the video we have done
similar videos to this so if a play was
missing in this video that you really
think should have been there go and
check out our other video it might be
there and if it's still not there let us
know maybe we'll do another one of these
videos in the future thanks for watching
guys and i'll see you all in the next
one
it was his clutch in that second half
that spurred on this whole fanatic
retake but the bomb not parted for him
that could work in his favor they were
not ready for this position but now as
it's the 1v1 on simple it's kind of
simple just hop on the bomb and stick
that defuse crimson
and still wins the round simple does it
with flair